حول مطار كابول حياة مدللة أو
مدللة
عند بوابة واحدة ، لقد علقت في
طلقات التصادم في الهواء ،
سمح لنا الجنود الأفغان بالدخول من خلال ثقب
في السياج
داخل عدد قليل من الأفغان المحظوظين الذين ما زالوا أمامهم
خطوات
للذهاب وأرقوا من مشاة البحرية الأمريكية ،
وبعضهم لم يولد قبل 9 سنوات  11 الذين كانت
لمحاتهم الأولى لأفغانستان هنا هي نفسها
مثل الكثير من قبلهم باستثناء هذه المرة
كانوا محاصرين حقًا من قبل طالبان الهادئة في
الخارج وكانوا
يتركون مخلفات 20 عامًا من المحاولة كانت في
كل مكان
المركبات التي قد تُترك ورائهم
ثم الأفغان  الذين لن يقوموا
بتعتيم وجوههم لحمايتهم
محظوظين بما يكفي للحصول على رحلة ولكن ليس
بأعداد كبيرة مثل أولئك الذين
اجتاحوا المطار في الأيام التي
سبقت لالتقاط الأنفاس ، انظر
حجم العملية الجارية هنا
للأشخاص الذين
يشعرون بالارتياح  كن في الداخل ولكن لا تزال
الرحلات الجوية يتم التقاطها مع حلول المساء ،
لكن الانقطاع الغريب عن
الفوضى التي كانت تدور حول
المطار فعل الناس داخل المطار
ببساطة  لا أعرف ما كان يحدث في الخارج
والداخل ، كانوا متجهين في اتجاه واحد
في أمن المطار ، وكان حكام البلاد
الجدد يعقدون مؤتمرهم الصحفي الأول
على تلفزيون أظهر بالتأكيد جميع
الرؤساء الأربعة الأمريكيين الذين كانوا
في حالة حرب هنا يجلسون وينتظرون  ليتم
دعوتهم إلى حياة جديدة في أرض الوفرة
أو أنهم سيهبطون بما يمكنهم حمله فقط مع
نيك بيتون والش سي إن إن كابول أفغانستان